RUSSIA AS WELL.
>> Bret: OKAY, JOHN,
THANK YOU.
SPEAKING OF THAT, LET'S GET THE
LATEST ON THE SITUATION RIGHT
NOW FROM SECRETARY OF STATE MIKE
POMPEO.
HE JOINS US FROM THE
STATE DEPARTMENT.
MR. SECRETARY, THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE.
>> BRET, GREAT TO BE HERE.
>> Bret: I HEARD AN INTERVIEW,
YOU SAID THAT NICOLAS MADURO WAS
ON HIS WAY OUT, PLANNING TO
LEAVE BY PLAINTIFF HAVANA, CUBA.
HOW CLOSE DID HE GET?
>> UNDERSTANDING THAT HE WAS
READY TO GO, HE MADE A DECISION
THAT WE HAD BEEN URGING THEM TO
MAKE FOR QUITE SOME TIME, HE WAS
DIVERTED FROM THAT ACTION BY THE
RUSSIANS.
WE HOPE HE WILL RECONSIDER AND
GET BACK ON THE PLANE.
WE'VE MADE IT VERY CLEAR, WE
SUPPORT THE NATIONAL SO TO
ASSEMBLY, THERE INTERIM
PRESIDENT JUAN GUAIDO, AND WE AR
PRESIDENT JUAN GUAIDO, AND WE AE
PRESIDENT JUAN GUAIDO, AND WE AS
PRESIDENT JUAN GUAIDO, AND WE AP
PRESIDENT JUAN GUAIDO, AND WE AO
PRESIDENT JUAN GUAIDO, AND WE AT
PRESIDENT JUAN GUAIDO, AND WE AN
PRESIDENT JUAN GUAIDO, AND WE AG
PRESIDENT JUAN GUAIDO, AND WE AT
PRESIDENT JUAN GUAIDO, AND WE AE
PRESIDENT JUAN GUAIDO, AND WE AV
PRESIDENT JUAN GUAIDO, AND WE AN
PRESIDENT JUAN GUAIDO, AND WE AZ
PRESIDENT JUAN GUAIDO, AND WE AE
PRESIDENT JUAN GUAIDO, AND WE AA
PRESIDENT JUAN GUAIDO, AND WE AN
PEOPLE, IT IS TIME TO BUILD BACK
THEIR ECONOMY SO THAT STARVING
CHILDREN AND THOSE THAT ARE SICK
CAN GET MEDICINE THAT IS SITTING
ON THE NATION'S BORDER.
>> Bret: WOULD HE HAVE A SAFE
PASSAGE TO HAVANA IF HE GOT ON
THAT PLANE?
>> WE'VE MADE VERY CLEAR WHAT
THE EXPECTATIONS FOR MADURO'S
DEPARTURE, FOR THE DEPARTURES OF
OTHER, TOO, AND WHAT HER
EXPECTATIONS, ASSURANCES WE ARE
WILLING TO PROVIDE, I WILL
NOT DISCUSS THOSE HERE.
>> Bret: BUT LIVING IS ONE OF
THEM?
>> BRET, I'M NOT GOING TO START
DOWN THAT PATH FOR YOU.
>> Bret: OKAY, WHAT ABOUT THE
RUSSIANS?
HAS BEEN COMMUNICATIONS WITH THE
RUSSIANS SINCE THEY TOLD HIM TO
STAY IN CARACAS?
>> BRET, I DON'T WANT TO GET
INTO ALL THE CONVERSATIONS WE
HAVE TODAY.
BUT IT'S VERY CLEAR.
THE CUBANS AND THE RUSSIANS
UNDERSTAND THAT THEY ARE
UPSETTING THE DULY ELECTED
LEADER THERE IN VENEZUELA.
THEY KNOW THAT.
I HEAR SOMETIMES PEOPLE SAY,
WELL, THE UNITED STATES IS
CONSIDERING AN INVASION.
THE INVASION HAS TAKEN PLACE.
THE CUBANS HAVE THOUSANDS OF
THEIR OFFICERS INSIDE OF THE
VENEZUELA TODAY.
THEY ARE NOT THERE WITH THE
CONSENT OF THE GOVERNMENT.
THEY ARE THERE WITH THE CONSENT
OF NICOLAS MADURO.
NOT JUAN GUAIDO, THE DULY
ELECTED LEADER OF THE VENEZUELAN
GOVERNMENT TODAY.
FOR THE RUSSIANS, IT'S THE SAME.
IT IS TIME FOR MADURO TO LEAVE,
TIME FOR THEM TO HAVE FREE AND
FAIR ELECTIONS, TIME TO REBUILD
THIS ONCE GREAT ECONOMY.
>> Bret: YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT
CUBA AND RUSSIA.
YOU HAVE, AS YOU LOOK AT THE MAP
HERE, 45 NATIONS AROUND THE
WORLD HAVE RECOGNIZED GUAIDO AS
THE LEADER OF VENEZUELA,
INCLUDING THE U.S.
BUT THERE ARE 14 COUNTRIES THAT
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT MADURO,
RUSSIA, CHINA, TURKEY, CUBA,
BOLIVIA, IRAN, NICARAGUA,
URUGUAY, SYRIA, BELARUS,
SOUTH AFRICA, CAMBODIA, AND
NORTH KOREA.
ARE YOU TURNING THE SCREWS ON
THESE COUNTRIES?
HOW IS THAT PRESSURE BUILDING TO
ACCEPT GUAIDO?
>> THE STATE DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN
HARD AT THIS.
WE ARE UP OVER 50 NATIONS, 54 OR
56 NATIONS THAT ARE SUPPORTING
JUAN GUAIDO.
WE ARE HAPPY TO HAVE THE 57TH
THE MOMENT WE CAN GET AT.
WE HAVE MADE CLEAR TO THE
NATIONS THAT YOU JUST CALLED
OUT, WE'VE MADE CLEAR TO THEM,
THEY ARE THE WRONG SIDE OF
HISTORY.
THE RULE OF LAW AND DEMOCRACY
ARE TO BE RESTORED.
THE DESTRUCTION THAT HAS TAKEN
PLACE OVER YEARS INSIDE OF
VENEZUELA WILL BE A STRUGGLE TO
REBUILD BUT IT IS A WORTHY
CAUSE, AND NICOLAS MADURO CANNOT
BE ANYWHERE IN THE COUNTRY IF
THE VENEZUELAN PEOPLE HELP TO
FINALLY ACHIEVE THAT OUTCOME.
I'M CONFIDENT THEY WILL GET
THERE AND THE UNITED STATES, THE
LIMA GROUP, COUNTRIES IN THE
REGION, THE ORGANIZATION, THEY
ARE ALL SUPPORTING NOT.
>> Bret: YOU MENTIONED THAT
SOME IN THE MADURO REGIME TALK
ABOUT THE U.S. POSSIBLY INVADING
VENEZUELA.
ONE OF THOSE WAS THE AMBASSADOR
TO THE U.N. FOR VENEZUELA, WHO
SAID THAT THE BUILDUP IN THE
EMBASSY IN BOGOTA COLUMBIA NEXT
DOOR HAS BEEN TO GET READY
FOR WAR.
LESSONS INTO THIS
>> THE PLAN, 3,000 OFFICERS,
3,000 TRAINERS, 3,000
TECHNICIANS, 3,000 INFORMATION
TECHNICIANS, IT'S A WAR EMBASSY.
SHOW ME WHERE IN THE WORLD THERE
ARE MORE THAN 3,000 AMERICANS IN
ONE EMBASSY.
SO THEY ARE PLANNING FOR WAR.
LET'S TAKE OFF THE BLINDFOLD AND
LOOK AT THE REALITY AS IT
ACTUALLY IS.
>> Bret: WHAT IS A RESPONSE
WITHOUT, AS WE LOOK AT LIVE
PICTURES IN CARACAS,
MR. SECRETARY?
>> WE NEVER TALK ABOUT THE
NUMBERS WE HAVE AT ANY
PARTICULAR EMBASSY.
THEY CHANGE FROM DAY-TO-DAY.
BUT IF THE QUESTION IS, IS THE
UNITED STATES PREPARED TO
CONSIDER MILITARY ACTION IF THAT
IS WHAT IT TAKES TO RESTORE THE
DEMOCRACY THEY ARE IN VENEZUELA,
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
CONSISTENT AND UNAMBIGUOUS
ABOUT THAT.
THE OPTION TO USE MILITARY FORCE
IS AVAILABLE IF THAT IS WHAT IS
ULTIMATELY CALLED FOR.
WE HOPE IT'S NOT.
WE HOPE THERE CAN BE A PEACEFUL
RESOLUTION AND THAT MADURO WILL
LEAVE WITHOUT VIOLENCE.
WE ARE WATCHING THOSE WHO ARE
ENGAGED IN VIOLENCE AND WE WILL
HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE.
THE PRESIDENT HAS MADE VERY,
VERY CLEAR THAT WE WILL ENSURE
THE VENEZUELAN DEMOCRACY IS
RESTORED.
>> Bret: NICOLAS MADURO ISSUED
A TWEET TODAY AND HE SAID NERVES
OF STEEL, SPOKEN TO ALL
COMMANDERS IN THE INTEGRAL
DEFENSE REGIONS AND INTEGRAL
DEFENSE OWNS AROUND THE COUNTRY,
WHO HAVE PLEDGED THEIR TOTAL
LOYALTY TO THE PEOPLE OF THE
CONSTITUTION AND THEIR
FATHERLAND.
CALL FOR MAXIMUM POPULAR
MOBILIZATION TO ASSURE THE
VICTORY OF PEACE.
WE WILL WIN."
MR. SECRETARY, THAT DOES NOT
SOUND LIKE A GUY THAT IS GETTING
READY TO LEAVE.
>> NERVES OF STEEL HASN'T SHOWN
US ALL VERY MUCH TODAY, BRET.
WHILE ONE WIDEOUT IS OUT TALKING
TO THE PEOPLE OF VENEZUELA, HE'S
ON THE STREETS SHAKING
HANDS, RALLYING, WHILE NICOLAS
MADURO HAS BEEN HIDING FOR THE
WHOLE DAY.
SO MUCH FOR NERVES OF STEEL.
>> Bret: AS WE ARE CONTINUING
TO LOOK LIVE THERE, WERE YOU
TAKEN BY SURPRISE THAT IT
HAPPENED ON THIS DAY AND NOT
TOMORROW?
>> WE'VE BEEN WORKING TO RESTORE
DEMOCRACY FOR MONTHS.
AS EVENTS UNFOLD DAY-TO-DAY, YOU
CAN NEVER PREDICT WHICH WAY IN
PARTICULAR DAYS WILL HAPPEN.
WE HAD KNOWN THERE WOULD ALWAYS
BE SOMEBODY THAT LOOKED ABOUT
LIKE TODAY IN THE SENSE THAT THE
INCREASING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
VENEZUELAN DEMOCRACY, WE ARE
CONTINUING TO SUPPORT THAT
EFFORT.
>> Bret: IS THERE A REDLINE IN
VENEZUELA IF MADURO DOES NEXT,
THE U.S. DOES SOMETHING?
>> WE HAVE PLANNED OUT LOTS OF
OPTIONS, WE ARE PREPARED FOR
LOTS OF THINGS.
I DON'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT WHAT
PARTICULAR ACTIONS MAY TRIGGER
PARTICULAR RESPONSES.
THE PRESIDENT JUST TALKED ABOUT
THE NEED FOR THE CUBANS TO
CHANGE THEIR WAYS AND WHAT WE
WILL DO IF THE CUBANS MAKE A
DECISION TO CONTINUE TO ENGAGE
IN VIOLENCE TO TAKE DOWN THE
DULY ELECTED LEADERSHIP IN
VENEZUELA.
BEYOND THAT, I DON'T WANT TO GET
INTO WHAT PARTICULAR LINES ARE.
THE VENEZUELAN PEOPLE SHOULD
KNOW, NOT JUST THE
UNITED STATES, BUT 50 PLUS
COUNTRIES, ORGANIZATION OF THE
AMERICAN STATES ARE CONTINUED TO
STAND WITH THEM.
>> Bret: MR. SECRETARY, TWO
MORE QUESTIONS.
NORTH KOREA, THE NORTH KOREANS
SAYING THEY NEEDS TO BE A NEW
APPROACH TO DENUCLEARIZATION.
ARE YOU STILL HOPEFUL THAT THAT
NEEDS TO COME TOGETHER, SEEING
WHAT YOU SEE NOW?
>> I AM, I STILL REMAIN HELPFUL.
THERE IS ONLY ONE REAL APPROACH
TO DO NUCLEAR RADIATION, THAT IS
TO DENUCLEARIZE.
TO BEGIN TO TAKE DOWN THE
THREAT.
WE ARE PREPARED TO ENGAGE IN
CONVERSATIONS TO ARRIVE AT A
PROCESS, BY WHICH THE
NORTH KOREANS CAN SEE THERE WERE
A CLEAR FULFILLING THE
COMMITMENT THAT CHAIRMAN KIM
MADE BACK IN SINGAPORE IN JUNE
OF LAST YEAR.
>> Bret: LAST THING, CABINET
SECRETARY, WOULD YOU BE
QUESTIONED BY STAFF MEMBERS ON
CAPITOL HILL?
>> [LAUGHS]
I HAVE NOT GIVEN IT 22ND
THOUGHT.
IT IS CERTAINLY, HAVING SERVED
IN CONGRESS FOR SIX YEARS, I
DON'T THINK IT WAS EVER THE CASE
OF THE COMMITTEE I WAS ON -- I
WAS AND PROBABLY HUNDREDS OF
EARRINGS -- I DON'T THINK I